hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the ipad air 2. uh now this can be a
pretty simple relatively easy review
video because we saw the ipad air 1 did
a review video of it last year and
overall as a category these ipads and
basically any large tablet have sort of
slowed down into this iteration year by
year we see them get a little bit better
but there aren't that many drastic
changes made so really the easiest way
to show this is to give you a list of
the ways it's changed versus the ipad
air 1. so these are all the changes made
to create the ipad air 2. so number one
is the ipad air 2 is thinner and lighter
than the first ipad air so the first one
was already really thin and light but
this new air 2 is just 0.96 pounds so
lighter and 6.1 millimeters thin so
thinner than any other tablet out there
and believe me that translates really
well from paper and just numbers to
actual hardware and holding in the hand
so the build of this thing is almost
surreal it's completely made of metal
all around which is great and it has
rounded sides and chamfered edges all
the way around too and it kind of just
feels like the display is attached to
almost nothing is at this point i mean
this is kind of the reason why i say it
feels like large tablets are hitting
their stride right now if you show this
ipad air to someone 10 years ago or even
5 years ago they'd probably flip out and
think it's impossibly thin there's no
way that's real
but it's not just about fitness the fact
that it's also lighter means it's just
as easy as any other tablet to hold in
the hand and while it's definitely not a
one-handed tablet it's much easier to
hold with one hand and type and poke
with the other hand
when this tablet is so light like this
so the side bezels are thinned out a
little but there's still plenty of room
to rest your thumb so overall it's
really well thought out i mean the
design we've seen it before
and it's sort of set a standard for
build quality and it's pretty deserving
of the name the only quirks with this
new thinner and lighter hardware is that
the mute switch that's been on the side
of every single ipad and iphone since
the beginning is now gone it's been
replaced with a software toggle in the
quick settings of ios 8 and i don't even
think that the tablet is too thin for
this it's just a i guess a design
decision by apple a conscious choice to
not have it but the other downside of
going so thin and light is the space
inside is a little bit smaller and that
means you have a smaller battery but the
thing is it's still a great battery life
for a tablet i didn't even notice having
to charge it more versus any other ipad
it has great stamina lasts basically all
day with any use and has the classic
ipad ridiculous standby time where you
can leave it at 85 percent not use it
for a week and pick it up to use it and
it'll be right ready at like 82 so
technically yes it is a smaller battery
it's a 15 smaller cell coming in at 7
340 milliamp hours and yes i should be
mad at them for sacrificing battery just
to make it thinner again but it's at the
point where i haven't actually yet
noticed a difference in battery life so
i guess that's something ios on a tablet
has going for it now one of the biggest
and best improvements of the ipad air 2
is its new display
it's still a retina display and it still
has the same 4x3 aspect ratio and 2048
by 1536 resolution still the same great
colors and color reproduction
brightness levels and everything like
that but it's now a fully laminated
display which actually ironically means
less air
between the glass and the panel so this
and the anti-reflective coating is
supposed to give the new screen a much
more glare-free look like the images
closer to the surface of the glass and i
actually thought it pretty much seemed
like i was touching the pixels like the
image was floating right on top of the
ipad as i touched it and the retina
display looked great
except i already thought that about the
old ipad screen so maybe they all look
great honestly you probably won't be
able to tell the difference until you
see them side by side i actually think
tai moss's speed test video accidentally
does a really good job of showing the
difference between the display on the
ipad air 2 and the original air i'll
link that below if you want to watch it
but besides that i did notice a little
bit of a black gap around the edges of
the display just a little bit of a gap
it's something i've noticed other
laminated displays have too and it would
be a little distracting sometimes but a
lot of times i just didn't even notice
and it would be less noticeable on the
gray ipad which has black front bezels
instead of white another improvement
with the air 2 is the specs inside so
the air 2 is rocking apple's new a8x
chip which is their best mobile chip yet
by a long shot and without getting too
technical it's essentially a triple core
three core processor
and you also now finally for the first
time in apple tablet history get two
gigabytes of ram now the a8x this chip
it's incredible it's super powerful it's
really thermally efficient this tablet
basically never heats up on me and it
powers ios 8 as smoothly as you'd expect
i mean this no hiccups here this is ios
8 at its finest there's not a whole lot
of extra stuff going on obviously it's
just a grid of icons but it better be
this smooth in 2014 with specs like this
but on a tablet i've said this before
everything feels like a blown up version
of the phone interface here on the ipad
it's not really taking much advantage of
all those pixels and all that power
and with two gigabytes of ram you would
think apple would find some awesome
seriously advanced ipad multitasking
stuff to throw in there but it's still
the same interface as any other granted
i'm sure apps will stay open in the
background longer without having to
refresh but honestly unless you're doing
some heavy gaming or messing with some
3d graphics apps or something really
intensive like that you're probably not
going to notice the spec difference
between the air 2 and the original air
even though it is a lot better so that
brings us to
the little things there are just a
couple of other little things sprinkled
in there to make this ipad air 2 a
really compelling tablet for a lot of
people
that they'll hopefully try to get them
to spend their money on they upgraded
the camera
now yes i know it's rocking an even
better 8 megapixel camera it's
essentially the exact same optics as the
iphone 5s and sure i'll give credit to
apple you're right the the ipad is
probably the best camera viewfinder out
there technically that's true uh and as
beautiful as it might be to look in
front of your face it still doesn't mean
you should take pictures all the time or
video with your tablet but hey the
iphone 5s took pretty good pictures so
now so does the ipad
you also get touch id now the
fingerprint sensor over the home button
that you can use to unlock the tablet
but it kind of stops short of a lot of
potential i mean there's no nfc so you
can't use it for apple pay but there are
no multiple account sign-ins on ios for
example so you can't sign into a
different profile with a different
fingerprint stuff like that's missing i
guess it's still the early stages of
touch id technically but basically it's
just for unlocking right now but it's
there and i also got to mention that
super reflective apple logo which was a
fingerprint magnet like crazy but when
the tablet's clean that thing is a
serious eye catcher and the speaker on
the ipad which was
very
very very loud so it's it's actually so
loud that it vibrates the entire tablet
at its loudest volume and then when you
put it down on a sort of a vibrating
surface like a wooden table the chassis
makes it even louder so it resonates
through whatever surface you put it on
so it's kind of funny
it's not the best quality in the world
and it's still sideways facing but the
loudness was impressive so overall as a
whole package you got to admit the ipad
air 2 is pretty sweet even though i'm
more into smaller tablets at the moment
like the nexus 9 and the ipad mini and
speaking of the ipad mini the ipad mini
3 which has come out recently i didn't
even want to touch it or talk about it
at all but essentially just for those of
you who are curious it is the same exact
product as the ipad mini 2 with retina
display just added a gold version and
touch id so what this essentially means
is the previous version which dropped
100
is now a really good deal and if you
want to continue spending full price to
get touch id and gold that's up to you
but i wouldn't recommend it i would
recommend specifically buying the ipad
mini 2 if you're into a smaller ipad but
i'm also going to be reviewing another
smaller tablet coming up soon the nexus
9 and a whole bunch of other things i
like i said november is a pretty busy
month for tech but this has been my
impressions of all the stuff that's new
in the ipad air 2 and you can choose for
yourself if you think that's worth
upgrading i personally would say
for some people but again it's up to you
so that's been it thank you for watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace
you